IT'S TIME FOR THE SEGMENT,
WE LIKE TO KEEP IT A HUNDRED.
FOR ALL YOU PEOPLE THAT DON'T
KNOW, THAT MEANS KEEP IT 100%
REAL. IF YOU DO, YOU GET A
STICKER. IF NOT, YOU GET
SOME WEAK TEA.  AND FEEL FREE TO
TEA BAG IF YOU LIKE
>> OKAY.
>> ALL RIGHT.
THIS IS-- OKAY, YEAH, WE'RE
GOING DO IT WE'RE GOING SAY,
I'M GOING ASK YOU WHO IS THE
GREATEST BOXER, OKAY.
AND YOU CAN'T SAY MIKE TYSON
BECAUSE I KNOW YOU WILL JUST
KISS HIS ASS.
EVEN IF IT'S TRUE, IT
DOESN'T MATTER.
>> TAKING IT OFF THE TABLE.
>> Larry: HERE'S WHY.
YOU HAVE TO NAME SOMEONE
ELSE AND WHEN YOU SAY WHO,
WHY THEY ARE THE GREATEST,
YOU HAVE TO TELL ME WHY THEY'D
BEAT MIKE TYSON, OKAY.
YOU'RE A BOXING FAN.
YOU'RE A BOXING FAN, YOU
SHOULD BE ABLE TO DO THIS,
MIKE, THEY SHOULD BE ABLE TO
DO THIS JACKIE, GO AHEAD WHO
IS THE GREATEST.
>> YOU'RE ASKING ME, WHO IS
THE GREATEST?
OF ALL TIME.
>> Larry: YEAH.
>> JOE LOUIS.
>> Larry: WHY WOULD HE BEAT
TYSON.
>> I THINK BECAUSE HE WAS
BECAUSE-- I'M 100% REAL
AND I DON'T --
>> TEA BAG HER, PLEASE.
CAN YOU --
>> NO, I'M BEING 100% REAL
RIGHT NOW.
>> Larry: OKAY.
>> AND I SAY THAT HE WOULD
BEAT MIKE TYSON BECAUSE HE
WAS A HELL OF A HEAVYWEIGHT
CHAMP.
>> Larry: THERE YOU GO.
>> THAT'S A LOT OF STUTTERING.
>> Larry: NO, I GET IT.
LZ.
>> I WAS GOING TO GO WITH
JOE LOUIS.
I GUESS I WILL GO WITH ALI.
>> Larry: WHY WHAT HE BEAT
MIKE TYSON.
>> BETTER REACH.
>> THAT'S GOOD.
>> Larry: AUDIENCE?
(APPLAUSE)
DID HE BELIEVE THAT?
(BOOING)
>> NO.
>> Larry: WHAT? BETTER REACH.
>> I THINK THE AUDIENCE WANTS
YOU TO HAVE WEAK TEA
>> YOU GOT TO SAY MORE THAN
THAT.
OKAY, KEITH, KEEP IT A 100.
WHO'S THE GREATEST?
>> YOU KNOW I WILL. IT'S ALI,
AND I WILL TELL YOU WHY.
BECAUSE TYSON SAID HE WOULD
BEAT HIM.
I WATCHED ONE OF YOUR
INTERVIEWS.
>> OKAY.
MIKE, I'M GOING TO DO A
DIFFERENT ONE WITH YOU.
I WANT YOUR HONEST OPINION.
I'M GOING TO GO THROUGH
THESE VERY FAST.
I WILL NAME BOXERS.
AND YOU JUST TELL ME, YOU
BEAT THEM, THEY BEAT YOU OR
DRAW.
>> OKAY.
>> SO GO THROUGH THESE FAST.
>> ALI.
>> ALI WINS.
>> JOE LOUIS.
>> I WIN.
>> ROCKY TWO.
>> GEORGE FOREMAN.
>> THIS MIGHT BE CLOSE.
>> MILLION DOLLAR BABY.
>> SHE MAY WIN.
>> APOLLO CREED.
>> I CAN TAKE HIM.
>> JAKE LAMOTTA
>> HE WINS.
>> ROBERT DE NIRO
>> I WILL GET HIM GOOD.
HE DON'T STAND A CHANCE.
>> ROBERT DE NIRO AS FAT JAKE
LAMOTTA.
>> IF I'M FAT TOO, HE HAS A
CHANCE.
>> ROBERT DE NIRO AS A YOUNG
GODFATHER.
>> HE MIGHT WIN BECAUSE HE
HAS THE GUNS AND STUFF.
>> Larry: SODA POP PENSKI
FROM MIKE TYSON'S PUNCHOUT
YOU KNOW SODA.
>> HE BEAT ME BEFORE.
HE BEAT YOU
>> PAUL SIMON WHILE HE IS
SINGING THE BOXER.
>> YOU COULD TAKE HIM.
>> Larry: ROCKY THREE.
>> THAT MIGHT BE CLOSE TOO.
>> ROCKY ONE.
>> I WOULD GET HIM.
>> ROCKY SIX.
>> I WOULD WIN.
>> ROCKY FOUR?
>> WAS I IN THAT ONE.
>> THINK ABOUT IT, MIKE,
ROCKY FOUR.
>> DID HE FIGHT THE RUSSIAN.
>> THERE IS NO WAY YOU ARE
BEATING ROCKY FOUR.
>> DID HE FIGHT THE RUSSIAN
GUY.
>> THAT WAS THREE.
>> HE BEAT THE RUSSIAN IN ROCKY
FOUR.
HE WOULD WIN.
>> THAT IS KEEPING IT 100.
WE'LL BE RIGHT BACK.